this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by upstart manscaped and raycom
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
social media
uh thank you guys every week i thank you
for your support i genuinely mean it
um make sure you're subscribed to the
youtube channel all right you guys
watching if you're watching just hit
subscribe
subscribe it up over there we've got the
time code so you can jump through
stories you see something you like you
can jump there
look down in the descriptions down there
where all the sponsors and stuff are
um the patreon audience is still growing
i thank you for your support on that i
know i say it all the time it's five
bucks a month and i say all the time
that sixty dollars is a lot a year i
know it is there's a utility bill people
are on
employment shit's going on i get it if
you're in for the long haul
and you can afford it you can save money
you can save over a month of free
episodes if you sign up for a year
patreon gives you that option now
so if you or anyone you know has a story
that needs to be heard please submit at
honeydewpodcast
gmail.com alright uh social media go
make sure you subscribe to the facebook
fan page the honeydewpodcast.com is the
website that's where the merch is
you guys are ripping it up out there in
night pants nation i'm telling you we
out we sold out the material
for the night pants we had to get some
different colors so you got some options
in there champion sweats now
stepping it up for you all right hoodies
all that it's cold get yourself some
[ __ ]
christmas is coming um i record here
every week at the santa monica music
center
so if you need musical instruments or if
you need lessons or your kids need them
or you want to take a lesson with your
kid
this is the spot you can get music
lessons
online from local los angeles musicians
all right here's what you do go to santa
monica music dot com
use my code honeydew they will waive the
registration fee
and give you one free lesson when you
sign up for a package all right
that's the biz there it is right there
now if you're new to the show
uh what we do over here is we highlight
the low lights
and i always say these are the stories
behind the storytellers
it is a pleasure to have this guest
return here i've been trying to make
this happen for a little while
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
honeydew adam ferrara
ah thank you brother welcome back bro
good to see you it's great to see you
and this is great the new studio is
great and i'm on the mic you're on the
mic on the mic
let them all know everybody's got a
problem yeah he's
funny but i can't hear i'm on the mic
um before we get into anything please
plug it all plug it on
okay well uh the atom for our podcast 30
minutes you'll never get back you can
get wherever you get your podcast
my dear friend ryan sickler's been on
there uh i don't know when this drops
but coming up
uh ralph macchio uh that's great i love
sweet sweet
i mean do you know him from we did
together and then um it was just when it
was just when cobra kai was coming out
so he was telling me about it
and you know when you when you're on a
set it's it's heightened reality and
you're working with your emotions so you
get
close whatever emotion is happening on a
set between people
gets elevated yes so it like i love you
i hate that [ __ ] either way it's
gonna get bigger so um
we just became friends because we we
played friends in in the movie uh
childhood friends and it was just us for
the whole second
act the two of us running around queens
so uh he was telling me about cobra kai
because it was just when that was
starting to happen
uh and i called him when i started the
podcast and uh he said yeah let me do it
when
i can promote stuff so yeah he did one
for me nathan lane did one for me which
was great yeah
your episode was great uh thank you i
was i had fun doing it yeah it was great
just two of us in the garage
you know oh that's my ride i got that's
a little pulse with a call
yeah and the cider was on the mic
we don't want to hear you [ __ ] aaron's
too quiet
so yeah if you're a sports fan i had joe
buck on yeah yeah that's great
uh tony kornheiser and michael wilbon
from pti
both on you i got uh michael imperioli
coming up
uh paul reiser uh so it's it's nice and
you know we get to talk to our friends
and we get to
this gives us you an entree to reach out
to people you wouldn't
ever ever really but also people i'm a
fan of who i don't know you know i
didn't know you prior to doing this
yeah i didn't know you and i really
connected with you i really have a good
time talking to you and the other thing
too is like
you know i even though i do know some of
these people
i don't you when you sit down i'm like i
didn't know that about you yeah i've
been i've been
working comedy with you for 10 years and
i and i know you
i've hung out with you but i don't know
this about you you know so i've enjoyed
finding out new things about old friends
that i didn't know about i didn't know
paul reizer was a classical pianist
is he really yeah he plays a classical
piano he played the piano for his music
uh for the uh the music for uh mad about
you really
yeah and the story was he met uh he was
in an
airport with uh helen hunt and don was
the producer from
bonnie ray the stones and everything
they knew each other and he's like
i don't have a i don't have any music
i'm working on this thing he's like come
to my studio he goes in new york yeah
i'm landing they goes come tonight
and they just did it no [ __ ] yeah they
tried to get lyle lovett to sing it
he passed
when it came back he did it again i
kicked myself
[Laughter]
i wore out lyle lovett and his large
band that
that album yeah oh that's great yeah all
right so tell me what's going on with
you man
what's going on uh we're talking about
his i don't know if you knew this about
me i know well last time i said we
talked about therapy but did you get
panic attacks i had um
what i thought was a panic attack but
when i described it people said hey no
it's a hard time
you sure it's not in my mind i don't
know why this [ __ ] arm my jaw
is telling me this [ __ ] i can't lift my
arm up to touch my jaw
the people basically said yo you're new
to this
a panic attack is crippling what you had
was a mild panic attack but but to me it
did not feel mild because it was my
first
anything ever like that i was with uh
segora on tour
um we're in atlantic city at this uh
what is it though
i can't remember the newest casino there
it's gorgeous organa
no i can't remember now we did so many
goddamn
shows but we're going up these
escalators and i say these escalators
because you know there's
it's this one yeah then it's this one oh
yeah and you don't like escalating and
then it's this one
and now i'm like okay and i'm looking
over the side and we're way the f
and there's still one more to go and i'm
like and i start saying [ __ ] like man if
i fell off this i could die and some
stranger behind me is like dude why are
you saying that i was like i don't know
i don't know i don't know and then we
got on that next one
i i couldn't breathe i turned i sat down
i faced everybody on the escalator i put
my hands like this i just breathed i was
like just tell me when i'm close to the
top so i can turn around and
[ __ ] step off this thing and i
started getting
and what i knew what it what tipped it
off was that my daughter
had almost got hit by a car and it was a
close call that just
unnerved me and just [ __ ] me up and
i went i talked to dr drew about it he
sent me to emdr
therapy and and basically she's like
look you you've been fine
but that anxiety's been lying there
dormant yeah and that moment right there
is what popped it all up and it was like
surprise
and i got scared to fly i you know i
wouldn't
i used to love i used to put music on
and we'd shoot down that runway and i'd
feel like a [ __ ] rock star
now i'm i'm looking at everybody i'm
looking around i'm listening to every
squeak i'm like
those wheels don't sound good going up
they don't sound normal
ah i get so [ __ ] i'm like oh this is
your
that's how i started to feel i started
to sit in the aisle
so i could walk more and get up and
and then she you know through therapy
with her she was like look
these are it's not real because what i
told her was
when my daughter almost got hit i
couldn't stop thinking about what didn't
happen she goes there it is right there
yeah she goes you're
she called it future tripping i've
talked about it on the show she's like
i said i couldn't for two weeks i saw a
brutal ugly
event in my mind that didn't happen yeah
and that's what she's like you're
conditioned
to the trauma from your past of making
you feel a certain way and what you're
feeling are the
the feelings that this anxiety is
dredging up you're not really feeling
what you felt
because you should feel relief nothing
happened you know she's safe
whatever and then i went to therapy for
a while really started working on it i
had to fly during it i was like i'm not
hiding from this we're like i'm going to
tell you how i do i'm going to be back
here i'm getting on that [ __ ] flight
i would start watching planes in the air
waiting to see if one would just go
i did i was just i was i was
going to park i'm gonna get to the
bottom of this myself
i was flying a kite with my daughter in
playa and you can see all the planes
taking off there and i kept
i watched everyone take off i watched to
see if anyone
had mechanical problems or any of this
[ __ ] i started researching terp
all of it oh that one before yeah and
it was all about that that fear of
losing someone and death and dying like
i'm worried about crashing i'm worried
about falling off these heights i was
never scared of heights before i
wouldn't cross these crazy bridges and
[ __ ] like [ __ ] i'll sit in the car i was
all sitting the car guy
and um i worked on it and i kept working
on i'm still working on it but
i knew that i was better when um i was
having dinner at my daughter's mother's
house one night and and
there's three of us and my daughter gets
up and she just walks away from the
table and we're talking
and i just think she's going to use the
restroom but then she comes back
and she's red and starting and grabbing
her throat and her mom's like are you
choking and she didn't know what to do i
got up high i'm like
boom flew right out done and i didn't
panic i didn't panic i didn't freak out
i didn't
i didn't start thinking about oh my god
if i didn't get that out or what if i
wasn't here
none of it so i knew the therapy worked
and was working and i just knew
i needed to just keep that [ __ ] in mind
that this is
what i'm feeling is not what what's
happening it's from other [ __ ]
yeah let me ask you this do you think
there's any
value or in any healing kind of uh
energy in the fact that your daughter
was in trouble and you got to her and
you got you didn't panic and you were
able to save her and that was a closure
of
it felt like it could have been a
clothing yes it felt like control
it felt like knowing what to do like
everything slowed down i was like
you're a lifeguard you got this you got
to do a heimlich i gave her a pop-pop
[ __ ] shot right out
um and i know that she's got the little
sternum so i didn't go hard you know i
knew where to position it
all that stuff all care your preparation
met that moment
it did and she coughed out an airplane
and boom and then the next day i go to
school
oh i'm healed look what my daughter did
and like the dad's like i heard you
saved your daughter's life and i was
like
nothing you know it was lovely yeah yeah
if it weren't for me she'd be dead she
wouldn't be here today i'll tell you
that it'd be an absentee day
yeah well that see what you you
described as the way to describe it to
me it's like
you had that anxiety you had that trauma
and it's it needed a place to go so it's
like that wore away
for lack of a better term your your your
emotional immune system
so you had a cold you had that big
trauma and then when when that little
door opened
aha you know it's like sonic the
hedgehog [ __ ] without
running around it had just been chilling
yeah on vacation for like 20 years but i
didn't know what mine was
my the first one i got i no [ __ ] i
was just but also let me say this is why
i said i thought i had a what a panic
attack on that escalator and that's what
people were like you had a mild panic
attack
how is that mild i don't know it's very
terrifying
apparently you a lot of people have felt
like they were having literal heart
attacks even went to the hospital and
stuff like that i didn't i knew i didn't
need to go to the hospital
i just didn't know what the [ __ ] was
going on okay you know
[ __ ] then i had mild like i didn't go to
a hospital because i wasn't gonna go
it doesn't feel mild that's what i try
to explain especially when you don't
even know you've
never had this no i didn't know what to
do i couldn't
my thing was where were you the first
time it hit me i was in my apartment in
new york
and how old are you
i gotta be i'm gonna say i'm 30.
okay you're young yeah 30. um and i had
a corporate gig
for affleck in jersey all right so i had
to go through that
sorry i got a bit more i ryan i don't
know what the [ __ ] triggered it but i
holy [ __ ] and i'm sitting there going
did i did someone dose me you know i
didn't know
what it was um and i just literally out
of nowhere
i don't know it was shaking i don't i i
wasn't aware enough to know what was
going on in my life where oh
this must be a reaction too like i
didn't have the tools to
to come up with any kind of reason but i
knew i had to do something i was like
nervous i had to get out of the
apartment i went to the gig it was two
o'clock in the afternoon i drove to the
gig
that was there at eight o'clock at night
yeah because i didn't know what to do i
knew i had to get to that gig and i was
so nervous
i guess i latched on to work i'm gonna
lose the gig i drove to new jersey i was
there at 3 30 in the parking lot for an
eight o'clock o'clock gig
for affleck the [ __ ] duck didn't even
show up yet
there's nobody in the parking lot
they're not even set up i drove back
home again because i didn't know what to
do i'm like okay now that i'm here
i needed to give myself an assignment to
do something because i didn't know what
to do
and i was terrified and the gig went
fine nobody knew but inside i was
screaming
inside it was like and all i heard was
pink floyd
you know the lunatic is in your head
because it felt like that
it was a distant kind of feeling so i
want to ask you about that real quick
because
for me the saving grace for me has been
the stage it has not mattered what i've
been going through that amount of time
i'm whether i'm up there for 15 minutes
or an hour
yeah it all goes away yeah um but you
said
you felt it during that journey that i
did what was that like how do you even
[ __ ] concentrate on what you want to
say i can't even imagine
feeling what i felt like excuse me that
escalator and trying to be on stage i
don't know
how you even pulled that off it was it
was a distant feeling it was
i was watching myself do it look i was
going to say you feel disconnected and
you're out there
disconnected out there but it was like
it wasn't and i was still able to work
the crowd and stuff
um so you're present i was i was present
there
i was here yeah but i was watching that
guy do it here
right and and and then what really
helped me after that
was listening to my act because i audio
tape everything listening to my act
and um i was talking to dana gould about
this and dana
said oh you became a character in your
head
because when i listened to my act i went
oh that's who i am because you don't
know
i didn't know who i was i don't know if
you experienced that but i didn't like
i'm [ __ ] lost
i don't know who i was but listening to
my act i went oh that's who i am
so and dana pointed out that i became a
character in my head so that kind of
gave me something to hold on to yeah
he's one of the smart guys
yeah but he's a little bit scared i said
i gotta miss the big words
i remember i had him on um a while back
on the or i did his show actually and um
he i saw him years ago in this volvo
station wagon
and i saw him on laurel canyon we're
both going down two lane it's creeping
traffic and i see him
talking into a little uh cassette
recorder right and i was like
oh my god he's doing what it's dana
gould he's doing what i do i put my
you know those micro cassettes back
there i got all my ideas on this and
he's doing i thought man you're on the
right path and i go do a show and i'm
like
man this was years and years ago you had
that volvo station
he's like look out in the
that [ __ ] dude garage loved it like that
was the one right there that was it bro
i was driving i was uh when i was on top
gear they i would get
these press cars so i so i could drive
them for a couple days and then yeah you
offered to let me drive that [ __ ]
i couldn't get there i was so devastated
it was a mustang yeah
it was a shelby gt350 ah i was like dude
get over here i got it for three days
i'm devastated so i'm driving when the
cts-v came out the cadillac right they
sent me the coupe
and i'm driving it right real quick when
you get that bronco let me know the new
one yeah yeah
let me know that looks fun the other
thing the other thing i don't know about
the front face of it because
it looks it looks like it's surprised
it's back too
like i got that it's the headlights are
just too big hey
it's their new like they're getting rid
of well i have the edge
and they're getting rid of that for the
bronco but i'm like that's you're
leaning way into the off-road [ __ ] right
now
big time but they're gonna do what they
do with every mustang there's gonna be
different variants you're gonna get nine
different types you can have a family
fort bronx
yeah so they're going to do all of that
but so so i got the cts
and i like cadillac's because look at me
[Laughter]
let's be honest
so and my wife so and this is the ctsv i
think at that point i'm going to say 640
horsepower supercharged i could be wrong
on the horsepower
but it was nice to have a manual
transmission it was and had the
magneride in it the ferrari actually
took the magneride from gm which is you
can you can adjust the uh
there's fluids uh in the shocks and you
you turn a dial and the metal filings
of this electrical current and metal
filings in a fluid that stiffens up the
suspension in the car
in the in in the actual car this was a
switch yeah just
that you you put the electrical charge
in and the metal filings stiffen up
the uh the suspension so i'm driving and
my wife is like
it's a cadillac and i said yes it is and
she she's like you know
it's it's an old it's a it's an old
man's car i said honey look i know you
think that this is an old gandaloons car
but this
is a luxury coupe sports vehicle this is
this
this is a performance vehicle here at
that moment we're going down beverly
boulevard
joe pantalioni pulls up lowers his
window and says
so do you like it
it's a commercial a commercial joey
pants
i'm trying to convince my wife i'm not
an old gindaloon
and this
[Music]
but it's amazing who you see out here
yeah it's ridiculous
it's just you see people like i i can't
believe
sometimes especially when we get just
doing the podcast and seeing people
in the wild is just amazing me i saw
cameron manheim at a bed bath and beyond
and she helped me with my sag insurance
because she's on the board
i was just talking to her oh
and yeah so so in getting the panic
attacks i wanted to ask you about this
do they did they come back did they
recur
aft after after the uh you you helped
your daughter and you feel like they had
closure did they come back at all
they haven't only because i've stayed
away from heights and flights
you know mine came back i'm built but
i'm not saying
i feel like when i start flying again
they're going to come back because
flying is i also realize it's control
and but also with that i realize how
absurdly ridiculous it is
that you know there's nothing i i'm not
gonna walk up to that cockpit and be
like move guys get the [ __ ] out
you know what i mean like there's
nothing i can do
and i don't like that feeling of being
at someone else's mercy you know
well how are you dealing with all this
[ __ ] because this because when the
pandemic hit
the here's where i i learned i because
of my crazy i'm kind of aware of my
crazy now because
what what that panic attack did to me is
it opened the door of me being
i gotta [ __ ] fix this because i was
still working and i was
they would start getting better when i
was on i was on tour with uh leary
we were doing a rescue me comedy tour
and i'm on a tour bus and i'm getting
panic attacks i don't know what they are
and i don't know if you know this
there's a lot of cigarettes on the tour
bus there's there's no compassion i can
imagine there's a lot of
a lot of compassion on that passion
you know and there's not a lot of open
doors to talk about your feelings going
dennis you got a minute yeah so i
actually wrote a joke about because they
said you have to talk about it
that's the only way to get rid of is
talk therapy and doing it so i wrote a
joke
on the bus about it and did it that
night so that actually kind of helped
but um in taking the control of
everything when those pandemic hit
it actually helped me because i went oh
look i can't [ __ ] blame myself for
this
i can blame myself for a lot of [ __ ] but
i can't blame myself it is
but don't don't you think i tried i was
in i was at the improv in chicago
march 15th before they shut everything
down and i got on a plane the next day
and it's all shut down you got to get
home
and in my head i'm thinking to myself my
crazy head just went
look what you did you did yeah in my
head i caught myself thinking i was i
said i wanted to be home i wanted to
spend more time with my wife and i'm
yelling at myself i said
i meant series regular i didn't mean
global pandemic
don't hang this [ __ ] on me
i would have taken recurring anything
but that lack of control actually helped
me because
the elu being comfortable in uncertainty
is is what i've been trying to do now
because what there's no [ __ ] control
no [ __ ] control on me i i've been
talking about this too like
if it isn't the funniest thing as a
comedian to have
poured your entire everything into an
occupation
that some [ __ ] disease bat could just
wipe out if that isn't the biggest joke
of all yeah
like wait i've stressed and given up my
family
and friends for this job that i can't do
anymore you know
i say i think about like where's the
what's the beer man doing right now yeah
what's that what's that guy doing right
now what are all these people that are
have careers that depend on other human
beings to be present
and around doing around the globe it's
crazy geez hookers have to learn how to
type
yeah or just get online yeah just pay
somebody to get online for them
yeah i didn't i didn't think of the
what's the new delivery system and
you actually helped me when i first did
the podcast when i first did your
podcast because i just started mine
and uh i spoke yeah our mutual friend um
jeff fox yeah
jeff fox ryan's a good guy by the way
can i say this
i'm gonna say this cause i get asked all
the time you asked me to hacks on tap
yes those of you who listen to hacks on
top yes that is my voice and i was
telling adam
my uh producer jeff fox who works with
us as well
um said hey would you do this vo for me
and i was like yeah he's like a pay a
call like i don't need any
whatever that's for you i'll do this for
you i had no idea
and i'm saying i should do better
research i didn't look up anything i
just read this thing it could have been
for some
who the hell knows i know if it was
coming from jeff yeah jeff's not going
to knock on the door
uh so listen this is giving open it's
the children
we need your voice uh but yeah hacks on
tap that's yeah i get it a lot now i
have no idea how
i was listening to the other day when oh
i know that movie yeah yeah yeah
um man where the hell worked oh no but i
said when i was on jeff
when i asked you to podcast and and and
the control about how we can't do our
jobs now because of the audience but
this is the new delivery system
this is the new it has to be for now
right we're all
locked up yeah you know in this this is
the only these are the only human
interactions i really have outside of my
family that i've been with this is it i
i go home
i stay there um i don't do anything
there's not i mean la is a place where
you can't do much anyway it's not like
texas or even down in orange county
where they're 25
open you can go in places down there so
i found out about myself that i'm
i guess i'm more of um extrovert than i
thought i was but
but i i'm still at that point the per
type of person where i don't
i'm comfortable going out to dinner by
myself and being around it i don't need
to be in
it yeah which is what stand up really is
anyway we're not i'm not
intimately having conversations with
these people in the audience we're
entertaining a crowd of
400 500 whatever it is and then we're
leaving we don't
really other than a meet and greet with
anyone which now you can't do those
anyway
you're not getting to really know those
people so this way
they get to know you and then through
the patreons i'm getting to know a lot
of them
but i realized that i do i am more
social than i thought i was
uh but i have my my distance and
boundary well said
when i'm out there in that like i'm
still quiet well it's also
let me ask you this there's also a it's
not not that it's a chore but there's a
work aspect of i'm doing my job and my
job is
to present my my my art my artistic
my my act to you to make you laugh
there's an
energy exchange and it's also how do i
the heroine for stand up is the
immediate response
good or bad immediate reaction this
like we're recording a couple weeks
ahead so there is no response until this
goes out there is if you're off mike
get on the line yeah you're going to
hear that yeah no but
my next question was do you find this
satisfying the
conversation and putting together the
future yeah i do too here's the thing
even during normal times this was my
favorite [ __ ] this is why i like
these type of interview shows i like
this but i will tell you what's turned
the corner for me and i
that's i know you could probably feel it
shift with me too was this home school
[ __ ] when
oh yeah homeschool hit look i'm my first
job
is as a father and to keep my family
healthy
and thriving as all parents need to do
right now
and you know we have a governor who just
went to [ __ ] dinner
for his friend's 50th birthday party
whose kids are in school
has no idea how the rest of us down here
are [ __ ] living and trying to still
have
full-time jobs while still homeschooling
now my daughter this is my problem it's
not a boohoo thing this is just my
situation everyone has theirs
my daughter's sick so she's learning how
to read she can't she isn't 10
8 where she can sit there on her own and
do what she needs to do it's
have have a helper nearby have someone
near have an adult nearby you know
they're kindergarteners so
half the week i am on zoom classes
helping her dude i'm a teacher's
assistant
yeah you know and i feel for the
teachers because you know the ignorance
of anyone to the ignorance of these
politicians to think anyone can do a
teacher's job
is just it's arrogant it's ignorant it's
absurd yeah these are
you know these who have first
universities for four years they go to
learn the [ __ ] and we're just supposed
to be able to do a teacher's job like no
i i can't and i don't want to and nor
should i so i gotta
i'm not qualified i'm not qualified
daddy taught me how to roll this
yeah i'm not qualified i wasn't good at
the old math you all went and changed it
and now i don't know how to teach the
new map i don't know how any of this
works
what'd you do with the remainder what's
your remainder where's your one you
didn't carry the one
what are you talking about do i gotta do
everything all right let me
pick up the one it's [ __ ] me up it
yeah it has put me behind
so far in life um like
you know i've got the two shows i'm
doing now plus three new ones plus the
post post-production on these things and
notes and working with ash like we're
just cranking
and it's there's days where i'm like i
can't even get back to that right now
because i'm in [ __ ] home school hell
and
i snapped a little bit the other day and
then i didn't know my daughter's mike
wasn't all mute but she was like dad i
don't like this i go you know what
i'm with you and i support it i don't
like it either
homeschool sucks it sucks but you know
what stella
we gotta do it we're not those people
we're gonna do it because we need to do
it
and that's it but you're right it sucks
and i hear this stella please make sure
your microphone's on mute i said stella
she started laughing i was like
[ __ ] i feel like she baited me
you know she has
never not had that mic on mute oh but i
did i snapped on him a little bit you
know
yeah well it's it's you have to juggle
all the balls like look
i'll show you the text dude [ __ ]
homeschool i can't do [ __ ]
it's and having that pressure that comes
back to control
you have to control it and you don't
have the expertise to control this and
i'm fortunate that that i
did invest in myself where i have a
studio because now it's like
you're going somewhere to work at least
you get that i do get to leave to do
that
but before if you were if you're at
someone else's network or you're in
someone else's studio
you have to go at the time they say they
have available
yeah i couldn't do that having a having
homeschooling you know i have to
this half of the week it's gone i can't
do [ __ ] day or night if i do
i got to pay a a tutor and a sitter yeah
you know what i mean then i'm starting
to hemorrhage money i can't i'm i'm not
at a place right now financially where i
could afford a tutor
every [ __ ] day i can't do it they're
not cheap anyway and who wants to come
over and tutor your [ __ ] kid
yeah during the goddamn coronaval yeah
is this what's she comfortable with
right you know what
yeah this the the i didn't realize how
much
i have been in and out of my house
because my wife runs the house you were
at the house yeah
i love your blood yeah i can't that
ain't me
i come to visit my [ __ ] i kiss my wife
i go out i talk about my dick to
strangers for cash
i come home
everything runs she's beautiful then at
night i lay in bed going how are you not
appreciating this
and then the panic attack's like
remember me yes
so i got all this but now that i'm home
i realized that
i'm noticing a bunch of [ __ ] and i'm
looking around and and i i [ __ ] up i
said
honey you do it this way what if you do
it like
and i got the look and i just went look
i know how busy i'll i'll just tell
myself to go [ __ ] myself so it's one
less thing you've got to do
yeah yeah so then i leave and i go for
every afternoon i have to put structure
i found structure and order helps the
crazy dude that's that's what i'm
lacking right now that's what's giving
me anxiety now is
i am a very structured person i like da
da da
and right now also with with the way
these income streams work yeah it's you
know if you get something from merch
that's 30 days if it's a sponsor it's up
to 90 days
if it's youtube it's this it's this so
you you can't even [ __ ] figure out
where the hell
you know then you got your sound
exchanges and your
you know this album and this and and
it's good to have this stuff coming but
you can't even
i can't i just got to stop saying you
right but budget
because i don't know when the [ __ ] it's
coming where it's coming from and how
much it is if
it's a great [ __ ] point you know so
everyone's got their problems with their
jobs right now and as as
you know we are not exempt at all
we're all in the same boat together yes
and uh and
i need them to rerun some [ __ ] movies
baby
but i also you asked me i find this um
therapeutic i find it relieving i find
it this is so
i mean i get to sit and talk to people
and and it's nice you know
we're not just not that i'm not enjoying
talking about this because i haven't for
a while we don't just sit and talk about
the coronavirus like people are coming
in here and
yeah i think a lot of people are even
more in touch with that [ __ ] right now
because they're
they've got so much [ __ ] free time
well yeah that was the other thing is
now that i feel
more pressure with all this free time to
create stuff so i'm reading i'm right
i'm trying to
keep again the revenue streams i got the
new my new album came out that did great
so i'm still
plugging that um and i'm then i'm
reading that shakespeare wrote king lear
during
during a pandemic i wrote six dick jokes
one of them has a mask
that's on fast and i'm like what am i
accomplished what am i going to come out
of here with
[Laughter]
now i got the pressure to that i needed
to read that [ __ ] thing
but you we all we also have to keep
doing what we do
you know like i still go this actually
happened you go to therapy on zoom
no i haven't done them have you yeah
friends of mine have
yeah so now it becomes it actually
right it became i mean the honeydew with
y'all is my therapy on zoom subscribe
today
there you go that's it anytime you work
in a plug like that
you're seamless five bucks a month but
if you sign up for a year
save them off a month of plus a free
episode see that yeah
that's great i went so i go to therapy
on zoom and it's more of
uh because you're used to going there
and i've seen this guy for years
now it's more of an intimate experience
for me because i'm in his home
so he's talking to me i'm looking at
zoom and i start thinking
he didn't read those [ __ ] books all
the ones behind him yeah the books
he's got a 4k in his office i'm paying
this guy way too
so yeah look at that he took the [ __ ]
kids at disneyland
last year is that when i was having my
heart attacks i see the [ __ ] date on
that screen
no wonder i couldn't get you so i'm
looking at this thing
and he's talking to me and i internalize
everything
so i beat myself up and i i respond
rather than i react rather than a
response so it's just that emotional
thing
now i've learned that that reaction is
valid that instinct is valid on stage
and it's valid in when in acting but
it's in your life you want to come from
choice and you want to choose how you
want to be and that defines your care
all that [ __ ] right
so i'm talking to him and in the middle
of it he said adam the
the key to your therapy is to not is to
come from choice like we discussed and
at that moment his wife yells
marty the dog [ __ ] on the stairs
what's your again marty your body goes
like this what are you gonna do marty
excuse me
he covers the camera and he goes i'm
working rita
the shovel and the bucket are in a
laundry room give me a freaking break
please
adam anger is corrosive gross
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor manscape now
listen up
fellas 2020 sucked it's almost a new
year which means
new balls with our sponsor manscaped
manscaped is the best in men's below the
waste grooming offering precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
and helping 2 million men all over the
world get rid of hair on their balls
if you let yourself go in 2020 i don't
blame you but while we're in quarantine
manscaped is here for you to reboot and
stay clean and shaved in 2021.
you know 2020 for me i gotta say a lot
of a lot of
not so great things happen like for all
of you but man homeschooling's been the
worst
the worst all right i need a fresh
start and manscaped is here to give you
a fresh start in 2021 with their perfect
package 3.0 that has all the right tools
for the job
come out a quarantine with clean balls
thanks to the lawn mower
3.0 this waterproof and skin safe
trimmer
will reduce nicks to your two best
friends the third generation tremor
even has a light to give you the glow up
you need in 2021
it's also time to freshen up down there
this new year
the crop preserve is an anti-chafing
ball deodorant and moisturizer
you always put deodorant on your armpits
why the hell
aren't you putting deodorant on the
smelliest part of your body your ball
bag
and for the on the go freshness you'll
love the crop reviver
ball toner spray who doesn't need to
revive their balls
20 20 was awful so make sure your boys
are refreshed and ready for new
beginnings
in 2021 manscaped even threw in their
shed travel bag
to keep all your goodies stored
comfortably and speaking of comfort the
manscaped anti-chafing boxer briefs are
also included
and are hands down the best underwear
you will ever
wear a guy with hairy balls is like the
year 2020
don't be that guy get 20 off and free
shipping with the code honeydew
at manscaped.com your balls will thank
you
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code honeydew at manscape.com again
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code honeydew happy
new year to your balls
our next sponsor is upstart now there's
a lot of economic chatter right now
about the state of the market
is it recovering how long will it take
have we seen the worst
but if you are struggling to pay off
high interest credit card debt
you cannot wait for those answers you
need to take action
and now with upstart there's actually
something you can do today
to help fight off high interest credit
card debt upstart
is the revolutionary online lending
platform that knows you're more than
just a credit score
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your job history in the
form of a smarter rate
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online they
offer loans from a thousand dollars all
the way up to fifty thousand dollars so
you can consolidate your debt
into one easy fixed rate payment okay
upstart makes it fast and simple to
check your rate
and since it's just a soft pull it will
not affect your credit score the hard
pull happens
if you accept your rate and proceed with
your application and the best part
is if the loan is approved and accepted
most people get their funds
the very next business day over 500 000
people have used upstart to pay off
credit cards or meet their financial
goals free yourself from the burden of
high interest credit card debt and get
back to using your money
your way with upstart listen i know a
lot of you are using upstart you've hit
me up about it
and you hear me promoting it they
they're great okay
if you're on the fence i'm telling you
try it out you can see why upstart has
over six thousand five star reviews
on trustpilot and hurry to upstart.com
honeydew to find out how low your
upstart rate can be checking your rate
only takes a few minutes listen
upstart.com
slash honeydew our next sponsor is
raycon
so here's another way 2020 is throwing
us for a loop the holidays right
lots of my go-to gifts are non-starters
this year there's no sporting events
there's no concerts there's no dining
out
and after everything that's happened
this year i want to get everyone on my
list a gift that will actually make them
go hey thanks i needed this i'm actually
going to use this
my silver bullet gift idea raycon
wireless earbuds look
a lot of you hit me up you've gotten
them and you love them i love them
i've used them for got a couple years
now i
travel with them i'm walking with them
exercising when i can with them
and just using them around the house
cleaning everything they're great
with seamless bluetooth pairing and a
comfortable noise isolating fit you can
start listening right out of the box and
keep listening for hours the audio
quality is amazing it's comparable to
what you get from other premium brands
except raycon start at half the price
best of all this is something they can
use for calls or music for work or play
at home or on the go it's the gift that
keeps on giving
and if they already have a pair of
wireless earbuds you always need a spare
all right raycon's being very generous
for the holidays so on top of their
everyday great prices
they're offering my listeners 15 off
right now so go to buy ratecon dot com
slash honeydew today
to get 15 percent off your recon order
that's by raycon
dot com slash honeydew by ratecomb.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do i
felt so much better after that
[Music]
yeah but that's the thing is to keep
going we were talking before we turned
the mics on about doing gigs and stuff
i had so much fun at this gig in
pennsylvania it was outdoors it was cold
everyone showed up in
their own hood that they just wanted
their they're they're hungry to be
honest
i'm on stage they made a plywood stage i
i put my heart into that [ __ ] show
and i had a great time
people were hugging human beings
overcoming together i'm
grateful that i have the capacity not
only to notice that
but to let that in and to enjoy that and
to give back to that energy so that's
that's
one of the things i look for in that in
what we're going through now
and it helps it helps if you can
identify positive and allow it in
because
i wouldn't allow it in one i felt i
didn't deserve it and two i didn't trust
it
italians don't really i just i just
talked about all the guilt the
plus the it's you've got all the family
[ __ ] thrown on top of catholic guilt
i mean all the guilt of
don't touch yourself don't do that don't
don't
don't don't don't and it's like man and
i i
someone asked me it was uh my guest
chelsea skidmore she said do you still
pray and i said i don't anymore okay
but i used to i used to pray every night
when i was in bed but mostly because i
felt like if i didn't pray
then all my dead relatives my dad my
gran they would i would be letting them
down i would somehow not be sending this
blessing to overlook them and keep them
protected in this
heaven or wherever the [ __ ] they are you
were coming from fear
yes you were coming from black and guilt
all of it oh it's all guilt all
of it but fear of letting them down or
you know this
[ __ ] that you carry for years and
years and years
and i don't mean to say that religion is
but
for me it's what it became and i just
couldn't take the
i needed i needed something to
be connected to that was greater than
myself my wife taught me that i looked
at her eyes went
holy [ __ ] you know i better lock this up
before this kid changes her mind yeah
you know
so i felt connected to something greater
than myself but did you grow up a
catholic kid right oh yeah
but did you go to church a lot or were
you holidays his thing
my my father sat me down right and he he
never liked herd mentality he never
liked follow mob mentality never liked
that at all
but he was he was practicing my father
he said listen
you've been baptized you made your
confirmation you made your first
communion
all your paperwork's done yeah i got it
too i got all my
case just just in case we got it covered
yeah
all right you want to go to church you
can go on sunday i'll be here watching
football
audios yes yeah that was it yeah
but the what i'm discovering when i set
out on my
i started meditating because with the
panic attacks came the men they put me
on meds
yeah so now i'm on meds you know it was
funny i go to see the shrink goes what
are your symptoms like my symptoms are
this
what do you got for that
what do you got for that
oh so they give you they give you the
xanax at night going
oh it's five o'clock adam gets his pill
uh which is nice i make it to five
o'clock and then they gave me the
antidepressants which was
[ __ ] horrible i i threw them away i
and i met my wife and i i remember
thinking to myself
this woman makes me feel better these
[ __ ] pills so whatever it is
that's working i'll go there um so i was
medicating stuff and and i knew i it
wasn't right
so i had to throw throw all that stuff
away and learn how to
meditate to just get control of the mind
because i realized that it was the mind
and get control of the thoughts and
disconnect from the thoughts so i
realized that's what i learned
you're just letting your mind run away
from itself yes like whoa
yeah you know what it's like it's i
always i always liken it to
uh when i was a you you watch your
thoughts
but you you're sitting there looking at
your thoughts going look at these
[ __ ] idiots yeah you just let them
wander around
but you we i didn't know not to identify
with my thoughts not to go into the
thoughts so when you could i have that
separation now
with meditation and and in med and
studying to get better and in reading
text and stuff
i went back to the quotes that they try
to teach me catholicism and i realized
oh it's the way you [ __ ] taught it to
me that made me feel bad and it was
you know he's dead your fault yeah he
did this for you yeah he died for
yourselves
[Laughter]
we told you not to touch it well i hope
you enjoyed it
this is on you
oh my god but in reaching that stuff and
realizing
like you said future thought and stuff
and doom and then the
and the depression from looking back in
the past and regret
i i read something that really just
where
it took me out of the anger i had
towards the way it was taught to me
is if you know the the uh lead us not in
temptation but deliver us from evil
you know we all know but that's the
future
stop with the stories and just tell me
what is the
i feel like there was this addendum to
the um
our father that i never really knew but
i would hear it at other catholic
churches but it was not it's
you know our father who art in heaven
i'll be the name of the kingdom come
come come on we've done ourselves and
give us the other bread for good sources
these aren't temptations deliveries
and then what is it for thine is the
power and there's a
there you know what i'm talking about
god is the oh that's is that the king
james i don't know there's like this
vines and [ __ ] yes thousand lines that's
king james yeah
i don't know man it was always this i
always went like this girl george
our father who's in heaven harold is his
name i i thought his name was harold
i did harold is jesus h christ
h dance dude if you're not saying that
on stage you [ __ ] i am now i mean
that was true my father jesus h christ
that's harold it stands for harold it
says it right there in the prayer we
said every sunday oh i was so
i could church was terrifying for me
because i didn't
understand it and i thought everyone
else did
yeah and i was like [ __ ] it's so somber
it's so
serious it's so boring for a kid
and to understand and the need to like
don't you feel the don't you feel jesus
no no i gotta turn around shake this
sweaty guy's hand behind
me and [ __ ] tell my name wash your
ass
but i didn't when i started meditating
and then just reading about what that is
because the basic
what helped me was the breakdown in that
someone taught to me
uh was the human condition is suffering
welcome
yeah negative thoughts causes the
suffering remove the thoughts remove the
suffering meditation is the key to do
i'm like oh it's a practice it's like
going to the gym
i can separate now so now in looking
back
now i was like oh that's what that means
so i
put down my resentment towards the fact
that i didn't get it and i thought this
was all my fault
and i disconnected from the control
issues of any organized
thing makes you behave a certain way to
fulfill an agenda
and i could look at it from a place of
oh that's what that meant
before it was twisted and taught to me
the way it was
it says appreciation for it which i
think helps
so tell me your worst at your worst
attack
what was it like and where were you what
was happening well i was getting
i was getting them on sorry real quick
your first one started you said around
30. i was about 30
and then how often were they coming
after well this was this was
uh during a time where i was
i wasn't where i was supposed to be but
i didn't know that until i looked back
yeah so inside well said yeah someone
was looking like
i'm gonna keep knocking till you open
his door you know because we live our
lives
going forward and we learn by looking
back
and um i didn't know that i thought
you're supposed to know this thing as
you were going it's like
friends our age i got i got a friend of
mine he's all right he's dating a 22
year old girl
he's like i don't think it's going to
work out stop thinking it's not going to
work out it's not
enjoy it while it laughs accept it it's
not gonna work out
he's like but i have feelings for us ah
it's cute it's not gonna work
he's like why is it you're at the point
in your life where you're talking about
the past
and this lady doesn't have one whole
life she don't have a pass
her past was breakfast after you get
paid
everything to look forward to your
shit's over
you're on the back nine and her story
was i had the oatmeal instead of the
eggs
yeah that is the truth that's it so
in in in being able to look back and go
oh that's why
that happened and that's why that was
happening to me
or that's why i didn't notice what was
going on is a
is a better way of doing it and
um what i what i learned was
there's a with lack of control but
there's a place to sit
where you can observe that now and i
flicker in and out of it
you know i'm like oh okay i don't have
to respond to the stimulus i can go oh
that's what that means like when i talk
to my wife
she doesn't want to tell me you know she
she'll tell me about what
what's going on i go she wants to be
near me and this is what it's about i
don't have to solve it because i'm
fixing everything
and when i'm in that mode i'm like give
me the bottom line baby i
i gotta paint move buy something what is
it you need
she just wants to hear the story you
know she wants to connect with a story
so
that helped me a great deal by and i can
enjoy my wife
more than i've only been married geez
uh it's gotta be almost 12 15. wow
12 year 12 years yeah something cause we
lived together before that so it's it's
like it
it was it's all a blur after a while
yeah you know and then there's the
markers in your life like my dad
i think we talked about my dad last time
i was here and he got ill and he died so
i know that he got ill in 2006. he died
in 2010 and
that's the marker um but we've been
together so long that
what happens with me with my wife now
knowing this there's a whole new
appreciation for it i'm like oh okay
look at and she does the podcast with me
so yeah she's creating with me
and and it's uh if you can get to that
point
of appreciation not only in a
relationship but in life
it it makes the these times a little
more um not palatable but uh
uh easier not to conquer but
a little less fearful and more like all
right what can i make out of this
i mean that's you know the mostly it was
the confusion at the beginning of all
this yeah
is this going to be a month to you know
they didn't know what the [ __ ] was going
on they still don't know they still
don't know
so at some point you got to you know
grab yourself
and be like all right what are we going
to do here how can we [ __ ] do it
just tell him what we got to keep going
we got to eat today
why we got to [ __ ] tomorrow yeah that's
it let's go yeah
and you just keep going and this this is
actually like because i
i know you have to be strong for your
daughter and you do we've had
i've talked to you before you're like
you know i'm going to take care of this
this motherboard
so i'm not going to have the child that
i had no your job was to give her
a better yes and i do that with my wife
you know i see her when she's spinning
and she sees me when i'm spinning so
when i say look
people have lived through these things
before and we're going to beat those
people
you know this is just what we're going
to do the money's going to come money's
going to go we will
we have to have confidence in our
ability to overcome and i love you then
i go in the bathroom
i shut the door i look in the mirror and
i go i don't know what i'm doing
how long is this [ __ ] gonna go on [ __ ]
yeah yeah i have those problems
showers a good spot for them showers
like they can't hear the tears over the
over the water yeah
you're going for another one going for a
walk yeah yeah
all right well i've been saying i've
developed a weed smoking habit on top my
weed smoking it
[Laughter]
i got my um i have to do my weed walk i
make sure i got my work day done
and then it just i i allow myself time
to decompress
and i go a magic hour like you know
sunset's a little earlier now
so i'll walk down to the beach because
by the beach
it's beautiful all right get your ass
back to work back to work
yeah but you got to take the time to
empty the machine out otherwise the
panic attack
any any [ __ ] in the armor that anxiety
is going to rush in and blow it all up
so if you can control not control but
observe your thoughts
i don't know if i thought you know what
helped me is i changed the word think to
notice
because think makes you identify with
your thoughts i think there's an
ownership
tone and kind of command to that
word i think me um
you know what i noticed notice put you
back so you're observing
observing it you know versus actively
thinking about you're
watching something okay because you
don't have to notice gives you that half
a beat to connect to it from church
give me an example um all right i
i i noticed that guy's he's always angry
oh you know what i think that guy's
always angry he's an [ __ ]
i noticed that guy's always an [ __ ]
that's such a better way to say
something right just hey i noticed
you're an [ __ ] i noticed you're an
[ __ ]
i think you're an [ __ ] i think you're
an ad i notice you're an [ __ ] that is
such a better way to insult somebody oh
i'm i'm at 47. i'm throwing that in my
arsenal hey
i noticed your ass yeah have you ever
picked up on this
it just struck me i happen to notice
you're an ass
have you done something with your hair
no i think i think you're an
[ __ ] i'm just oh god
oh man that is [ __ ] god i can't wait
i just
i might randomly upset somebody today
just use it on them to get it out of my
system
i can't wait to say it yeah i had a
whole thing yesterday i have not
popped off on somebody in you know in
quite a while
even with stupidity whatever yesterday
i'm at the drive-thru
i get a i get a large unsweetened iced
tea
it's all i getting and i'm at the pay
window
and they got the guy at the you know he
must have had a special order they said
pull up to that space right there
yeah but he's right in front of me and i
can see he's having words with a
young kid that works there right and
the kid's like whatever and he walks
away and i hear that guy in the in the
car he's got a jeep cherokee he goes uh
what's your name
and then the kid doesn't say anything so
i'm about to i get my drink and i'm
about to pull out and this dude backs up
and i mean he pulls
within an inch of me so i can't move
right
and i'm i mean the drive-through
window's right here i can't get out of
my car to go
i would literally have to climb into the
passenger seat to go out that door to
come around which i didn't think looked
very masculine
[Laughter]
and the guy's not moving i'm like move
your [ __ ] truck dude i gotta go
and he's like i asked for the manager i
go you can pull over there and talk to
the [ __ ] manager so the manager comes
in
and she's like what's going on i go this
[ __ ] has blocked me in
i can't leave i just want to [ __ ] go
he's like i want the match or go
move your [ __ ] truck i'm blowing the
horn and [ __ ] but i can't get out i
can't do anything
and then fine i'm like get out are you
the manager she goes yeah i'm like get
out there and deal with this dude
so she goes out and makes him leave and
i just pull up and he's got his window
down i go hey and he looks at me i go
i can i don't know what's going on here
but i can tell you're the [ __ ]
problem and i just drove away
but i wish i could have said hey you
know what i don't understand
i wish i had that yesterday i wish i had
that yesterday
that is such a i feel like people have
to process that
wait he knows
what is it what is it about me that
you've noticed that triggered that
response
i had a guy oh god i had a guy the other
day
it was it was a guy it was a woman and
she was driving
and there was a guy next to him and i
was coming out of the bank so the car is
here
there's no directional on they but and
so this lane is open i had to make a
right turn so
you know it's not a marked street and
there's no light you know uh wilshire
when you come when you hit the wrong
side street on wilshire there's no light
you're like [ __ ] i'm here for a day now
i'm here for an hour and a half so i'm
here so i i go this way
they were making a right but she didn't
have a directional so i just
did this i just inched out i made the
right and she she went to do it i guess
she oh she know i was there because it
was a blind spot but i had no indication
that that's where she was going
pull up to the light i'm on this lane
now she's here so she's here and i'm
here and she's through my passenger
window she rolls down the window
she goes really sweet move yeah she's
yelling at me she's like
you know what and she's an older lady
she goes would you do that if your
mother was in the car and i went my
mother knows how to [ __ ] drive
her eyes
and the guy the guy sitting next to her
he went like this he would you could say
he had one laugh
but he was like tell her again
say it i'm a hostage
i actually i actually felt bad because
she thought it was just some civilian
you know she wasn't like you know she
had no idea no i didn't where
we're who we are oh my god dude
you know because that that that you know
what that is that's the response that
was i didn't think about that line that
was
it's a heckler boom boom you're done
yeah
that's it and then the guilt comes in
after that
the guilt that you could have said some
better [ __ ]
i did not say this
i might call my brother and say it today
just to get it out this just i want to
put that into my
[ __ ] vocabulary that's funny so
what's the answer do we have one
to what feeling better
i mean look whatever here's what i
honestly think it is
whatever works for you whether it's
therapy
meditation both whether it's
walks yeah you know whether it's [ __ ]
long
drives i don't know i don't know yeah i
do too i don't know what the answer is
for each person but
you know the answer is you got to keep
moving forward you can't let the fear
hold you back you can't cancel flights
and work
and opportunity because you fear
something that
isn't even happening you know for me too
i would have to
the good thing i found out was that i'm
further ahead than i thought i was she's
like look if you can rationalize with
yourself
right you're already way ahead of most
people if you can sit there and go okay
look
you're on an escalator you're gonna be
you know she's like you're so far ahead
but
you know figuring out what it is why it
happens
and then moving forward is the only
thing you can do if it's medication it's
medication yeah
it is oh i'm not [ __ ] on that no i
know you're not like this wasn't right
for me
right i had taken some before a while
ago and i took it for like six months
and there was nothing
there was no change and i got off of it
um so but i'm i i
you know i'm not opposed to it no i
tried them all in fact i uh
uh i have uh add did you notice no okay
a little bit but they when they gave me
uh
it wasn't it was adderall it was it was
it wasn't riddling like
because i went and it's not like i think
i have it
halfway through the test i couldn't
focus the dog's like yeah i think yeah
you got it
so he gave me the prescription and it's
it's counterintuitive because it's
it's amphetamine and it [ __ ] expands
it was 120 bucks and i'm like a month
no 120 bucks for this prescription for
this thing you gave me i said what it
goes i said it says salt-based and fatty
because yeah
i can go to port authority get a bag of
whites for 30 dollars a bag of whites
yeah what is this [ __ ] you know i don't
need a fancy thing
so the counterintuitiveness of the
amphetamine
it just worked for my ad it focused you
um and when i discovered when i got a
panic attack the last one i got
was on top gear and that afternoon i
drove a ferrari
yeah tell me about this so how are you
not getting panic attacks on that show
with the speed and the danger and all
that well it's it's
that didn't trigger it for me i i i
don't think i was evolved
as you of knowing the triggering
incidents it was more of a
free-floating thing um so
that's the the issue is i'm sure there
is a triggering incident but my
awareness isn't there yet so i don't
know
so we're shooting i think we were utah
somewhere
something triggered it at night it
usually happens when i loosely so i
can't sleep so like i get up as soon as
i
try to fall asleep the flaw the
fight-or-flight mechanism
kicks in and i gotta get up and you know
i'm like the guy at a uh boogie nights
you know you play some baseball yeah
he's a chinese guy throwing um
so i'm tweaked out so we got to shoot
this thing where i'm in a an f12
berlinetta ferrari i gotta do a speed
run
it's 212 mile an hour car i think
i've never gone 200 miles an hour uh
fast as i had gone to that point was a
buck 80
in a uh yeah what was that lamborghini
superleggera okay
the gallardo superleggera um so i got
this it's [ __ ] stunning this car
and i'm doing a speed run and i hit
as i'm doing it i'm talking to the
camera i'm going through the gears and
this this [ __ ] thing is just like
just
this thing is just sex on wheels baby
and it just unleashes and i remember
sitting on come on get up and run
and it just started taking around a buck
40 car starts getting light you can feel
it
coming up and i'm calm
i was ryan i don't know what it was the
adrenaline
whatever it was i was just calm and i
just kept pushing it
and i hit around a buck 87 and i my
ass sensed the speed wobble which is
like dead
so i hit a buck 88 and then i ran out of
run there was a brake cone they put a
cone up we have to start braking here
because you're going to run out of
hit the brake cone at 188 i wanted to go
200 but i
couldn't get 188 188 and i uh
i was caught the adrenaline rush
calmed me down so i made him let me ask
you this question yeah
if you are a passenger in that car [ __ ]
myself yeah would have [ __ ] myself i
feel like
the control aspect of my hands on that
wheel and foot on the gas will make me
feel better
than sitting next to you while you're
doing that even if you were a nascar
driver and
over qualified to do that you know what
i mean yeah
i think i i think you're right but that
the i mean you made a mental note you
said the adrenaline
calmed me down so i don't know what so
you're telling me i should jump out of
the [ __ ] plane let's get a car
i'm just gonna parachute up to the front
i notice you need to swim with this
i ain't going all the way to jersey
lewis
this is good it's good right here
see on the ground i got a squirrel suit
and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
love you night pass nation
yeah no so i noticed that that
adrenaline does so maybe maybe it's a
wiring thing
maybe there's a counter-intuitive i i
don't know
i haven't gotten any since yeah that's
what i wanted to ask so you've had a
handful
of them but you haven't gotten any since
what since how long since that
i'll say 2000 what 15 16. so we might
have been
about four years i haven't gotten any
since um
my meditation is has kicked in because
what i've learned because i started
you know like you're on the road late at
night wayne died a bald guy comes on and
tells you if you breathe right you'll
get a series
you can manifest [ __ ] so that's how i
started and then
i realized that oh it's that wanting
it's that
needing it's that it's that it's that
self-seeking
in achievement for salvation there's no
achievement in salvation that there's a
temporary
healing there's a temple here this is
temporary sugar high
now i'm this yeah but it ain't going
anywhere
it's not built on anything so the key is
not to want that they're nice
and you want to do the best you can for
your family and experience
life whatever it is buddy of mine told
me his fear here's love
life happens in the [ __ ] middle of it
there's no end
which which part of the pole you want
yeah and i mean even if you
defeat the dragon and slay the dragon so
to speak it doesn't mean that in five
years that motherfucker's gonna be like
[ __ ] dragon yeah and it had a baby
yeah there's no
end to it there's the enjoyment you can
have in the moment and what is important
in that moment
and it's moments like this that makes
those scary ones better i'll leave here
like i gotta go to work after this i got
an interview after this
i'm gonna take this energy i'll have a
great time same i'm gonna just
i always walk out of here feeling great
yeah sometimes it's just listening to
other people
like man glad i'm not that bad yeah i
noticed that i noticed that guy
should stay away from sharp objects
well brother thank you for coming on
cause it's always a pleasure always
again please plug promote everything ah
the adam for our podcast
i'm very proud of it please check it out
wherever you get your podcast um
my new album is called it's scary in
here uh i was i'm very grateful that
debuted number one on itunes
god knows where it is now but jumped up
there uh and uh
and and the honeydew podcast is one of
my favorites i'm happy to be here thank
you
thank you brother you're welcome anytime
um and as always ryan sickler on all
social media ryan sickler.com we'll talk
to you all
next week
[Applause]
[Music]
you